welcome the waters world I'm Jessie
waters call it a tale of two presidents
Donald Trump and Barack Obama with
nearly back-to-back speeches this week
each rallying their party hoping to
garner support for the 2018 midterms but
their points of view couldn't be more
different
here's President Trump on jobs we've
added over 400,000 new manufacturing
jobs that the Democrats say are gone and
that numbers going to very shortly with
what's happening in certain areas be
well over 600,000 manufacturing jobs
african-american unemployment recently
achieved the lowest think of this the
lowest rate lowest ever recorded in the
history of our country now President
Obama had a little bit of a different
perspective with the economy and said he
took credit for it listen when you hear
how great the economy is doing right now
let's just remember when this recovery
started when the job numbers come out
monthly job numbers and suddenly
Republicans are saying it's America I
had to kind of remind them actually
those job numbers are the same as they
were in 2015 in 2016 here with reaction
former White House strategist dr.
Sebastian Gorka and author of the new
book mad politics keeping your sanity in
a world gone crazy after Gina Loudon so
dr. korkor I know that you've been glued
to the television watching President
Obama over and over because you missed
him so much am I wrong
that's not even funny Jesse okay I like
to I like not to be a subject of dr.
Gina's books okay so my mentor my mental
health is important to me so I love the
Trump rallies i watch my old boss every
chance i get but you know what the
community organizer pass hard pass it's
amazing he's now trying to take credit
for the economy after having
the weakest recovery since the Great
Depression but dr. Gina it's funny that
once you have the torch passed from
President Obama at a President Trump the
economy exploded there was a stock
market explosion wages have gone up
significantly there's been a
manufacturing explosion on almost every
level it hasn't been a continuation it's
been an explosion
an explosion we're talking about four
million jobs we're talking about
all-time record growth we're talking
about an economy we've never seen before
and Obama can't take credit for that
let's remember one thing we have a
businessman in the White House who has
made all of this happen I can't remember
if Obama ever actually held a job in the
private sector but I don't believe he
did I certainly know he never ran a
company he never did hard core
negotiations we're seeing the fruit of
that sort of a president right now and
Obama cannot take credit I would tell
President Obama you didn't build that so
it's also interesting that he's now
lecturing America and saying that we're
now in a place of deep hatred and
darkness and division here was the
former president's assessment about the
current state of affairs let's hear it
appealing to tribe appealing to fear
pitting one group against another
telling people that order insecurity
will be restored if it weren't for those
who don't look like us or don't sound
like us or don't pray like we do that's
an old playbook it's his oldest time now
dr. Gork I wasn't too long ago when
Barack Obama was disparaging the bitter
cleaners and telling Christians they
needed to get off their high horses and
he's one of the most divisive presidents
in the last hundred years in the polls
reflect that who said that at the
Thanksgiving table you need to get in
the face of family members who disagree
with you that's what he said look Jesse
you have an incredibly popular show you
have a light touch it's funny but I need
to be serious for a second
okay what he just said that clip you
showed is in affront and Ally nobody
nobody in the mainstream conservative
world nobody is saying we need to stop
the people who look different from us
yeah strong it could be a friend I mean
that it's it's reprehensible nobody is
saying the people of threat to us or the
people who look different from us if I
ever met this man I don't know if I ever
will but if I ever met Barack Obama
who's lying in that clip I'd ask him one
question just one question in the last
year the approval rating for Donald J
Trump from the black American population
has doubled jesse doubled how how does
Barack Obama explain that well maybe he
said it's Kanye's fault because baby me
told everybody to listen but you know
what I am making a joke but you're right
to insult half of America as bigots is
so reprehensible coming from a former
president and let's remember this was a
the first black president of America I
mean the majority of America red white
and blue black white everything voted
for this man twice to occupy the Oval
Office so this country is not a bigoted
country it's a very very beautiful
country that respects everybody and
listens to what they have to say isn't
that right yeah and another correction
of our dear former president we live in
a republic not a democracy and maybe he
needs a little history lesson there but
he is the king of identity politics II
he's the guy that divided us over and
over again for eight solid years the
division you see on television today
this was not created by this president
who has made everyone equal by making
record unemployment across the board as
the president mentioned for blacks for
Hispanics for Asians for high school
dropouts for crying out loud for summer
jobs for youth the unemployment is at
record low our economy is at record high
everybody benefits from that that is
true equality the likes of which Barack
Obama wouldn't
no no matter what I mean these things we
used to debate all the time on Fox News
if you were against Islamic terror he
would call you in Islamophobic right if
you wanted people to have to show ID
when they voted because you didn't want
voter fraud you were considered a racist
if you wanted a country that had borders
you were considered xenophobic under
Barack Obama and and it's just the same
old talking points that he used for the
last eight years
yeah it's tired old snowflake talking
points but let me just be very clear
about who the president is because we
have this anonymous opinion piece that
was published clearly by somebody who's
never spent any amount of serious time
in the Oval Office and has never worked
closely with the president and this is
what the left will never understand
Donald J Trump does what he does in
terms of securing America in terms of
unleashing the economy for all Americans
he doesn't care less who your skin color
your accent where you were born in fact
the stunning thing about this man Jesse
he doesn't care if you voted for him or
not if you voted for Hillary if you
wanted Bernie to win he doesn't care if
you're an American here legally he wants
you to be safe and he wants you and your
family to prosper end of story and the
left will never cognitively this is for
you know doctor Gina's specialty
cognitively they will never be able to
absorb that truth
well it's the trumped arrangements